so I'll spin out a couple of the
insights that I captured for blue Zone's
Kitchen on how they eat and no matter
where you go they're only using about 20
ingredients over and over and over
because they know how to combine these
ingredients number two they tend to
consume all their food in about an eight
hour window breakfast like a king lunch
like a prince dinner like a popper
number three they tend to say something
before the meal that marks the
punctuation between their busy life and
now we're slowing down to eat
Like a Prayer in the Adventists or the
sardinians or harahachi Buu which is a
confusion adage that the okinawans say
before every meal to remind themselves
to stop eating when their stomachs are
80 full they tend to eat with their
family not have Electronics in their
kitchens they tend to cook at home these
are all things that I would argue add to
the ecosystem of eating that produces
long-lived people and the core of which
being this knowing how to make
plant-based food taste delicious